[Musique]
merci Emy accue n TER là dans ton petit
cocon est-ce que nous peut dire que
cré ici oui le point très important
c'est que Ben men jou la case parce que
mon bon voisin il est très tolérant donc
c'est quand même un endroit où où on se
sent bien pour faire de la musique oui
parce que les instruments pour toi c'est
la flu traversière le saxo en fait moi
all est dans les instruments avant
depuis tanti parce que ben mon monté
enseigne ça à l'école de musique à
saintemis et du coup m'a grandi avec la
flute à bec puis la flute traversière et
beaucoup beaucoup plus tard le saxophone
donc c'est vrai que mon domaine de
prédilection c'est les instruments
avant
[Musique]
on on a une préférence pour le soprano
ça c'est mon ça c'est mon mon chéri doux
on va dire pour moi c'est le le
saxophone soprano c'est vraiment comme
une grosse Flut à bec et est-ce que vous
l' toujours dit à que vous ça faire
carrière dans la musique en fait si
quand m avait 17 ans voulais être
flutiste
concertiste rentre dans un grosorchestre
classique et fait le tour du monde
c'était le projet
évidemment la pass passe comme ça quitte
la Réunion juste après le bac pour fait
des des études de musicologie et après
première scène elle est devenue
évident la prend un petit peu de temps
c'est la musique rignonnaise que la que
la paraê plus que que la scène vraiment
commment a commence jouer avec un groupe
là-bas que il appelle auréol et ma
découvre ma culture en fait ma musique
mon pays et c'est ça que la là
apparaître vraiment comme une évidence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
are projet c'est ce projet maloya jazz
maloya expérience oui la base les maloya
mais la musique qui reste libre et libre
comme le maloya en fait chacun il
apporte sa couleur chacun y apporte son
jazz chacun y apporte son expérience
dans cette musique là c'est ça que c'est
ça que ma aimé quea voulu mettre en
avant et c'est pour ça l' important de
porter aussi au devant de du public la
musique instrumentale c'est le féminin
déjà d'être une femme leader de groupe
c'est difficile et ben mien beau avec ce
côté oui musique instrumentale c'est
vrai de M ah c'est sympa c'est chouette
ce que tu fais dommage tu chantes pas
oui mais ben c'est pas une obligation en
fait pour moi d'introduire le champ donc
mi ouais mi tient beau avec ce côté
instrumental en fait et c'est important
pour moi ouais c'est vraiment important
et dans cet
album tout frais mon pays
c'est la consécration et la
synthétisation de de 10 ans de vie pas
mon pays la Réunion en fait bien que
espère que M fait honneur mais c'est
vraiment mon pays intérieur mon fond de
cœur
[Musique]
monedans le plus difficile c'est de
traduire euh justement ce que l'on veut
dire dans la musique instrumentale mais
en même temps il trouve ça beau parce
que un moonc y écoute c'est que n'a
point de parole il est pas enfermé
làdedans il peut il permett à lit de
participer aussi en fait avec son esprit
son l'émotion du moment mais il fait son
propre film il fait construit son propre
histoire sur sur la musique est-ce qu'on
aurit un rêve à atteindre encore c'est
de pouvoir faire du live faire vivre
l'album en
[Musique]
fait c'est longue vie à à l'album mais
longue vie à à cette musique surtout
merci beaucoup Emy merci à d'être venu
jusque là pour permettre à moi de de
fait découvre de fait découvre mon mon
fond de C merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup